what is a force
it seems to be an idea that a lot of
people are confused about
it's like star wars is the only source
of knowledge
what is a force um it's like
jedi force is how you raise x-wings out
of
swamps you just concentrate what would
you say are forces
other than jedis
but outside of star wars a force
is energy and mass
so if you have a huge thing moving
really fast you got a lot of force
it's like getting hit by a truck as
opposed to getting hit by this tennis
ball
um forces energy that comes from
somewhere
something that exerts energy on all
other
matter the movement
the movement of
something in one direction and
the atmosphere
listen i don't know it's so this
indescribable thing that kind of keeps
us from flying off into space
nobody really knows what it's um about
it's just a theoretical
kind of thing and that should teach me
to interview philosophy students
but contrary to what she said there were
some people who knew
what force was about something that
makes something
move from its original position how you
propel something or how you get
something to move
or how to shape reshape something it's a
kind of
attraction or direction or something
like that that like an object has on it
yeah push yeah push or
a pull okay it took some coaching
but force is essentially just a push or
a pull
so then i asked people what forces are
acting on you right now
most could identify a downward
gravitational force towards the center
of the earth but
then things got a little bit hazy can
you tell me about the forces on you at
the moment
um well probably there's a big force
uh downwards towards the center of the
earth which is uh that's at
gravity what we call gravity i guess
well the gravity of earth
where is it where how does it act on you
well it keeps me
on the earth i it just i don't i don't
fly away
i would be standing on the earth and
it's pulling me down and making sure
that i'm stuck to the earth yeah
okay what other forces are on you are
there any other forces on you uh there
are there's air pressure forces around
me
uh there's my own muscular forces
keeping me up my skeletal forces those
kind of things
uh and also then uh different uh sort of
weather or climatic conditions
in terms of what like wind weather that
sort of thing or just
normal gravity is it what's keeping me
on the ground
it's not gravity so there's a
gravitational force pulling you down
yeah um any other forces that are acting
on you big friction
like on me right now on you right now i
can't think of anything excellent else
of gravity only one force it is i mean
surely there's like a lot of small ones
but
let me put this to you if there's only
one force on an object what does it do
uh it goes towards it but there is
another force acting on you which is a
pretty important one because there's
like there's a force acting down right
there's a gravitational force
what about a force acting up
no no up forces not that i can think
okay so what forces
are acting on you right now